[Music]
ready
let's do it
oh this works
hey what's up guys stoner for 2065.
today i'm going to be speedrunning
mcdonald's simulator
um i'm going to try to do with a couple
glitches here all right so here we go
credits okay here we go let me try again
[Music]
all right cool i just got to do it 64
more times and we go for the record hey
what's up what's up what's up lonely
loser 69 thank you for the bids
appreciate it
and uh do we have time for donations
yeah yeah give me some donations what's
going on what do we have uh
jack jack
jack skellington 85 has donated 10
he says good luck on the run royce uh
and everyone have a great games done
quick
thanks a lot man really appreciate it
we also have a donation for five dollars
from miami milf say
please stop skipping the cutscenes or
you're ruining the game yeah hey
somebody do me a favor put a boomer
filter on the chat
uh don't just make sure no one's allowed
to be chuggy in there thanks
guys remember we're doing this for
charity all right
there's no need to be mean
oh the next one is five dollars from
smack that ham
please
smack the ham the next time you do it
all right hey everybody press s in the
chat to smack the ham all right
that's in the chat i'll do it on the
next run
oh and it seems we've reached our
donation goal for the burger king dlc
thank you
royce will be speed running burger king
uh uh dinner time uh chicken tendy
fiasco dlc
uh which which which should be a great
time now what you're seeing here is i'm
doing this hack where you put terrible
disgusting onions on a breakfast
sandwich and what that's going to do is
that's going to glitch the game because
no one would actually order that and
it'll get me to the next breakfast scene
a lot quicker watch watch all this work
boom did you see that i just glitched
over here to the burritos i glitched the
burrito level all right here we go i'm
doing personal mark hey uh a moderator
what how much time do i have on the
speed run
okay thank you
uh this media donation is coming in from
big dig 69
yes i would like a lot of cup hey guys
come on remember this for charity kids
are listening let's try not to be gross
but thank you for the donation i
appreciate it